[Music]
it's gonna be a very happy holiday for
Gwen Stefani and Blake Shelton and only
we are worth going as she rehearses for
a time-honored Thanksgiving tradition
[Music]
when I walked out here and I saw the
stage I lost my breath I was like and
these buildings of it's New York and
this is actually the Macy's Thanksgiving
Parade happening I'm gonna be on the TV
and on the internet and I'm just oh I'm
so excited
first it's the parade in New York for
Gwen then Thanksgiving dinner with
sexiest man alive Blake and her boys we
will be in Oklahoma having an Oklahoma
Thanksgiving so full of love and so on
point with that silver fringy fashion I
choose the outfits based on what I would
fantasize about when I was eight years
old if I saw a princess girl walking
what I would want to look at and when I
walked out here all I do is look for the
little girls and I'm like
beautiful Gwen now she won't be the only
star at the parade hey Kevin and Kelly
you guys looking fantastic now hosting
the big event for CBS Cameron this is
one of the great traditions in this
country and this year expect to see 3.5
million people lining the streets of
Manhattan the big draw the new draw this
year is frozen's Olaf he is five stories
tall he's 60 feet long but another big
draw is of course country superstar the
girl of country music right now Kelsea
Ballerini will be playing two songs on
our show it will be a spectacular day
and of course we'll have the parade here
which always ends with Santa Claus
bringing in at the Christmas season by
the way please tweet us or Instagram us
and use the hashtag T day CBS and maybe
you'll make it on this show you could be
famous
[Music]
you